My happiest day
hasn't happened yet.
But it's about to.
On that day,
I'm going to get in my car
that smells like old tuna,
which will be packed
with all of my belongings
and my amazing daughter,
and I'm gonna drive
the fuck out of this town.
I'm going to drive
nine hours,
566 miles,
to Missoula, Montana,
where I'm going to spend
the next four years
learning to be a writer.
Hopefully there will be
a lot of happy days
during that time.
And I know there will be
some hard ones.
Most people
would bet against
the single mum putting
herself through college,
but they don't know
what it took to get here.
338 toilets cleaned,
seven types of
government assistance,
nine separate moves,
one night on
the ferry station floor,
and the entire third year
of my daughter's life.
But, when we get
to Missoula,
I'm going to take Maddy
up Sentinel Mountain,
which looks over the town,
and show her our new home.
I've been telling her
all about the giant M
that's at the tippy-top
of the mountain.
That the trail up there
is long and zigzaggy.
The hike will be hard.
But we're gonna
make it to the top.
And when we do,
I'm gonna tell her
that the M stands for Maddy.
That this whole new world
is for her.